♪ ♪
>> Greg: HAPPY THURSDAY,
EVERYONE.
OH, IT'S A BIG DAY HERE AT
FOX NEWS.
IT'S OUR 25TH AND MIKE
ANNIVERSARY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
25 YEARS AGO, THIS NETWORK WAS
LAUNCHED.
JOE BIDEN HAD JUST TURNED 69.
25 YEARS.
NORMALLY IF SOMETHING IS OVER
25, IT IS TOO OLD FOR ME.
BUT SO MUCH HAS HAPPENED IN THAT
TIME.
THIS WAS ME 25 YEARS AGO.
AND THIS IS ME NOW.
THAT IS WHAT YOU GET FOR TAKING
CARE OF YOURSELF, KAT.
NOT A DROP OF THAT'S BLOOD WENT
TO WASTE.
HERE IS KAT 25 YEARS AGO.
AND NOW HERE IS HER TODAY BUT
WITHOUT MAKEUP.
YEAH.
THANK GOD FOR OUR AMAZING HAIR
AND MAKEUP TEAM.
BY THE WAY, EMILY COMPAGNO IS
HERE TONIGHT.
HERE'S EMILY FROM 25 YEARS AGO.
WHILE BACK.
YOU HAVE CHANGED.
BUT I SO DON'T FOUL TOTALLY
SUPPORTIVE.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE BACK WHEN WE
STARTED?
UNLIKE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, WERE
AFRAID TO TAKE CHANCES.
ALSO DIDN'T DRUG TEST US BACK
THEN.
HERE IS OUR FIRST MORNING SHOW
CALLED MARSHMALLOW AND FRIENDS.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT DID NOT WIN AT A DAYTIME
ANIME.
I REMEMBER PETER DOOCY HAVING TO
BASH BECAUSE HE STARTED CHOKING
ON ONE OF THOSE LITTLE BLOGGERS.
THEIR RATINGS PLUNGED AND HE
SURVIVED.
WE ALSO CREATED HARD-HITTING
PRIME TIME PROGRAMMING.
LIKE THE SLOP FACTOR --
OUR MOTTO BACK THEN WAS WE SLAP,
YOU DECIDE HOW HARD.
THAT'S ALSO WRITTEN IN LIPSTICK
ABOUT THE MIRROR ABOVE MY
WATERBED.
THAT IS TO COGROUNDS.
BUT PEOPLE ALSO CAME TO FOX FOR
THE PERSONALITIES.
UNLIKE PLACES LIKE CNN WHERE
HAPLESS DRONES REGURGITATED
WORDS FROM THE TELEPROMPTER.
LOOK AT THIS BUNCH.
YOU FIND MORE CHARISMA ON A
CORNER'S TABLE.
THE FOX CREATED LAOIS OHMIC
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ITS VIEWERS.
YOU PROBABLY DON'T REMEMBER THIS
LIVELY DEBATE SHOW.
>> VERY STUPID, DOCTOR.
YOU SHOULD KNOW BETTER THAN TO
ATTACK US.
>> BUT WE DID NOT ATTACK.
>> SILENCE.
>> Greg: THEY WERE OUR WOW
ARGUING OVER THE IRAQ WAR.
THEN THERE'S THE LATE NIGHT
SHOW, LET'S TALK ABOUT SAX.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: HE HAS CHANGED A LOT.
THAT WENT ON FROM 11:00 P.M. TO
5:00 A.M.
THE STATEMENT ON THAT GUY.
AND OF COURSE THIS WAS OUR
AFTERNOON CHAT SHOW CALLED "WE
EAT CHILDREN."
>> I HAVE JUST BEEN TO THE TOY
SHOP.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I BOUGHT?
SHOULD I SHOW YOU?
IT'S A GLOVE PUPPET.
AND YOU KNOW YOU CAN DO ALL
SORTS OF THINGS WITH A PUPPET.
>> Greg: AND THOSE THINGS WE
CAN SHOW YOU.
WE CUT OUT THE PART WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY DO EAT THE CHILDREN.
OR WE CAN SHOW, HOWEVER, WAS
CALLED "FERRIS WHEEL LOSERS."
♪ ♪
>> Greg: THAT SHOW WAS THE
GENESIS FOR OUTNUMBERED.
FINALLY, WE LAUNCHED OUR
BUSINESS CHANNEL WITH ULTIMATE
STOCK TIPS.
YEAH.
HE WAS SOME KIND OF HOST.
THAT GUY GOT ME TO BUY BUY A LOT
OF STOCK IN ENRON.
WE HAVE GROWN A LOT SINCE THEN.
NOT ME, I'VE ACTUALLY SHRUNK.
BUT I DON'T THINK THERE HAS BEEN
A SUCCESS STORY QUITE LIKE FOX.
COMING OUT OF NOWHERE, MOCKED BY
THE MAINSTREAM, AND THEN BEATING
THE HILL AND THE LIVES OUT OF
ALL OF THEM.
ALL THE OTHER NETWORKS LOVE TO
ALL OVER US AND THEN SUDDENLY
THEY'LL TRY TO BECOME US.
FOX NEWS QUICKLY BECAME NUMBER
ONE AND MADE THE OTHER NETWORKS,
OF COURSE, LOOK LIKE THEY WERE
NUMBER TWO'S.
THAT'S FOR ONE REASON.
THEY DON'T LIKE IT WASN'T
AFRAID.
WE HAVE BIGGER BOWLS ON THE
CIRCUS ELEPHANT.
FOX WAS IN TRYING TO FIT IN AT
THE COOL KIDS TABLE.
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR COMPETITION,
THEY WERE TERRIFIED OF UPSETTING
THEIR INDUSTRY PEERS WHICH IS
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU ALL PLAY
FOR THE SAME TEAM.
FOX SAID SCREW THAT.
THERE'S AN ENTIRE COUNTRY NOT
BEING SERVED AND WE ARE TAKING A
NAP.
I WONDER WHAT LIFE WOULD BE LIKE
WITHOUT FOX NEWS.
JUST IMAGINE IF THERE WAS ONLY
ONE PERSPECTIVE IN OTHER AREAS
OF LIFE.
>> YEAH.
I WAS THROWING THE FOOTBALL
AROUND MY KIDS AND MY ELBOW IS
KILLING ME.
>> THAT'S FOR SURE TERMINAL.
>> TERMINAL?
SHOULDN'T I GET A SECOND
OPINION?
>> SORRY.
I'M THE ONLY ONE IN TOWN AND I
KNOW FOR A FACT YOU ARE GOING TO
DIE.
>> I REALLY HAVE NO OTHER
CHOICES?
>> NO.
DON'T WORRY, WHEN YOU ARE GONE,
I WILL TAKE GOOD CARE OF YOUR
WIFE.
>> EASY, CUOMO.
>> Greg: I GOT TO FOX
FULL-TIME 13 YEARS AGO.
YOU REMIND REMEMBER THIS
THIS IS REDEYE A NEW SHOW ABOUT
POLITICS, POP CULTURE, AND
MACRAME.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE LARRY KING BUT
WITHOUT THE DEAD GUY.
FIRST THING WE WILL TALK
ABOUT --
[APPLAUSE]
YEAH.
THAT HAS AGED WELL.
LIKE A LOAF OF WHITE BREAD THAT
FELL BEHIND REFRIGERATOR FIVE
YEARS AGO.
BUT AS ODD AS THAT SHOW WAS, FOX
STOOD BY IT LIKE A NURSE BESIDE
A GRAVELY ILL PATIENT.
OF COURSE THEY PUT US ON AT 3M.
I THINK IT WAS THE FIRST SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
THEY HIT US LIKE A BODY IN THE
TRUNK OF A SERIAL KILLER'S CAR
BUT THEY ALSO SAW SOMETHING IN
ME BESIDE A PINT OF GIN AND 25
BAR ALL OF US.
THE TALENT, AND THEY KNEW I WAS
A MAN THEY WANTED TO SEE AT
3:00 A.M. IN EASTERN TIME ZONE
ON TV INSTEAD OF OUTSIDE THEIR
WINDOWS CROUCHED IN THE BUSHES.
BUT I'M GRATEFUL TO FOX.
IT'S AMAZING THEY HIRED ME AFTER
THE VISITING ANGELS FIRED ME.
THEY FOUND OUT I WAS STEALING
BEDPANS.
THEY MAKE GREAT DINNER PLATES.
BUT HISTORY HAS A WAY OF
REPEATING ITSELF.
THE WAY FOX NEWS ENTERED THE
ARENA AND CLOBBERED MAINSTREAM
NEWS, THIS SHOW, NOW, IS DOING
THE SAME THING WITH LATE NIGHT.
THE MEDIA TREATED US LIKE A
JOKE.
NOW THE NO MIKE WE ARE THE ONES
DELIVERING THE PUNCH LINES.
[APPLAUSE]
AND EVERY NIGHT, MILLIONS OF YOU
ARE LAUGHING ALONG WITH US.
THE CURRENT CROP OF STALE,
BORING, PARTISAN LATE NICE HOST
INTERESTED IN HAVING
NANCY PELOSI WRITE THEIR SCRIPTS
THAN THEY ARE IN KEEPING THEIR
AUDIENCES INTERESTED.
AN "SNL" WON'T EVEN MAKE FUN OF
JOE BIDEN.
NO WONDER THEY HAD THEIR LOWEST
RATED SHOW LAST WEEK.
BUT THIS FOLLOWS THE GAME PLAN A
FOX NEWS.
LOOK AT WHAT ALL THE SHEEP ARE
DOING AND PROVIDE WHAT IS
MISSING.
THE HUMOR, AND THE FUN.
FOX NEWS ALSO LOVES THIS
COUNTRY.
AND FOR THAT, FOX SET APART FROM
THE OTHER MEDIA TYPES WHO
THOUGHT --
AS SEEN AND EVOLVED INTO A
SHRILL CLOWN CAR, WE LAUGHED